[Music]
so I'm I'm going to start out by
actually prefacing everything I say by
today you I'm going to congratulate you
because you apparently just got like
706 Goya nominations 13 13 just 13 so
congratulations on
that so maybe I should go I'm I'm going
to in well I why don't you introduce
everybody I'm going to introduce James
gray one of the best
now we have Roberto gessa he's uh one of
the
survivors we have eno binik who is
playing numma in the
film excellent interpret translator
Norma and we have our cinematographer
ped
luk
thank
you I'm I'm going to use my phone so I
can remember everybody you I know yeah
for about how many years many years um I
want to start out by asking you about uh
something that I think is uh really
fabulous about the movie among many
things which is the POV and how you
handle the point of view because you got
essentially a narrator from the
dead and it's not like Sunset Boulevard
where it starts off and you see it and
all that this is a very interesting I
don't think I've ever seen it where
somebody starts narrated in film and
then they die what two-thirds of the way
in can you talk about that decision and
what it means I I have my own Theory
which of course me being a bloviator I'm
going to tell everybody but I want to
know what you think yeah well first of
all I I think that you cannot limit the
adaptation of a of of a true story to
the fact you there's there
there there you need to add like like an
interpretation you need to add like an
aesthetic to it uh so uh we struggle a
lot in in writing the script because
every time we we we wrote we wrote the
story it was uh the the the we had like
a group of three writers with me the
very the very early draft it felt like
the other films because it was all about
dialogue and action dialogue and action
we needed an interpretation
and then um I thought about this
character Numa who who is uh so well
remember by by his colleagues and he is
remembered to to to be almost like like
like the example of what what what is
the Excellence of of in the mountain you
know and he died 10 days before the
rescue uh which raises a very
interesting question you know like
what's the meaning for that I mean we
always in these kind of stories of
heroism the one who does the best is the
one who gets the reward not in the case
of Numa and then I thought that
um by doing so I I was uh by telling the
story through through Numa I was some
kind touching what I really like about
the book uh Society of the snow which
was written 35 years after the plane
crash so you can you it's it's a more
spiritual even philosophical approach to
what happened because it has the the
rabit us of the time that had passed and
and I I thought by doing so by telling
the story Through The Eyes of a dead guy
I was touching that spiritual layer that
I love from from from the book and also
I I thought that I was giv the chance I
was giv the chance of what basically
happened in the mon is people people
giving everything they had to to to the
other one it's to me the the it's
the the way they they were giving their
their their everything the support the
the the animal and the body to the other
ones it's to me is to it's to understand
that you and the other one are the same
thing you know it's the the they were
doing doing that unconsciously is the
the unconscious realization that you and
I are the same thing and I was allowed
in the audience to experience death
which is that thing that always Alfred
hitchock says you cannot get
the protagonist because people will feel
cheated but in that situation people
were dying Yeah so basically what we're
doing is doing the the visual metaphor
of killing the audience experience death
and then allowing the audience to keep
the story through all the characters
which was basically what what these
people was doing yeah well I it's more
or less in line what I what I was
thinking which is that it it gives the
film a kind of religiosity if I may
sound pretentious because what happens
is is it becomes a myth of the Gods Not
Just a myth of man he's coming back from
the dead to talk with you and so the
film Embraces their religiosity because
religion is such a key aspect in their
souls um that was that was to me the the
the complexity on Numa is that he's a
myth on the Excellence you know but you
couldn't be excellent in the mon yeah
the group was excellent but when you go
to the particular when you go to the
individuals they
each of them measure the energy
differently and they had to deal with
with their with with their Shadows you
know so in it's in in the individuals
where you find that people that maybe
did didn't do that much survive and
people who did a lot uh didn't make it
that's why I'm using all the time this
kind of visual metaphor of Numa getting
Blinded By the Light because that's his
problem that is all about light Numa is
all about light and people is light and
Shadow we are we are people with fults
we are people uh with we are complex
people yeah and and when when when you
talk to the survivors when I talk to
Roberto and the other ones about Numa he
was a almost a myth of what what of of
the Excellence yeah yeah well it's also
I I mean we're here for like nine
minutes or something ridiculous so I'm
going to ask you one more question
unfortunately and then you can do all
the talking but okay um you got this
Ensemble basically it is an ensemble
like I say a myth of the Gods but it's
an ensemble and yet it's done very
subjectively which is very strange very
unusual right usually you see and it's
an ensemble it's almost like you have a
Gods ey view but you've handled a lot of
the sequences including with the use of
sound which I think is
extraordinary a very interior view does
this make sense to you or can you
explain this because I found that
unusual and in a great way I I really
wanted to make the audience feel like
like an immersive experience to to get
into the plane with
them so if you understand the context if
you will understand what they did
basically is is if you went through the
same experience they went
through this happened in in the we did a
screening for the families of the of the
survivors but also the families of the
of the victims and for the first time in
50 years some of them understood how
important where their brothers or or or
or their families for them to survive
and it's because we we we put people we
put the audience into into that plane
and also we wanted to give at least each
character a moment you know I I see Numa
a little bit like like Dorothy in in The
Wizard of O because she's he's
learning from all of them especially
from the dead he's making a self it's a
journey of self-discovery of
understanding what is your true nature
and accept it and being brave to to to
be it uh and he's a little bit like
Dorothy he he's talking to all the
characters and at the end he gets the
conclusion that okay this is the right
thing to do and he delivers himself to
the group I I do see the Judy Garland
resemblance now that I'm sing um so I I
I have to ask this question of Roberto
because he's sitting
here
I mean it's such a basic question but
what does it feel like to see this movie
for you what does it feel like is it
cathartic thrilling horrifying maybe
everything what does it feel like this
is the second time I see the
movie and I was completely moved
today and to the people in the audience
I don't know if many times you have
experienced what you experience today in
this movie how is something a story that
is unbelievable
was made
believable by the magic of
H and I see the the
actors
suffered in a way what we suffered in
the mountains I mean this is a story a
lot about suffering you see them suffer
I see Numa how he was suffering there so
I believe that probably would be a long
time until you get so moved and I tell
you because I was there and when I see
them how they felt their experience
although they were not us in their way
they climb the mountain and I think
that's that's a masterpiece of of the
film than than
today so along those lines Enzo I do you
when you're playing
you know a real person you haven't met
the person you don't know the person how
much of
a debt do you think you owe an idea of
the reality of that person or is it your
own idea
completely good
[Music]
luck
person
for
I said here we are she's
amazing well usually characters start
very far away from you and then you
start getting close to them and in this
case it's it felt real because it was a
real person and we felt and we owed them
a debt and the only way to do this is to
live what they live through and you know
feel that suffering so when we and when
we were filming we felt the reality we
felt the weight of what they lived and
also resp responsibility of what that
carried and there were many moments that
I lived through in this film but this
was actually the first time in my life
that while filming I felt the real
emotion coming through me like in the
case of the Avalanche like I felt the
real sense of distress like taking over
me and but I had to keep going because
we had to continue filming and um you
know this is the type of story that it's
impossible to tell without going through
that suffering we have have to go
through that and also feel the weight of
all of
[Applause]
that I suppose this is the perfect segue
to Mr
cinematographer
hello
um so because this evening is all about
me you understand I can tell you that uh
I shot a mov movie In the Jungle which
was very agonizing and I had I think two
days in the snow cap
Mountains and the snowcap
mountains led the jungle for difficulty
by a
mile I want you to talk me through this
brother you got up there digital right
huh you were with digital you you you
have a technician there with you with
his board and the whole thing or her
board I I you kind talk me through how
you did this it was I mean it was a it
was a difficult thing it was my fourth
movie in the snow basically I can't
believe it because I'm from Uruguay and
suddenly I I found myself again in the
snow but this time was like 140 days of
shooting in the and
um and it was very difficult uh just got
get to the set you know it took us like
a 20 minute ride in a Gondola and a 45
minute ride in a tractor basically and
um and yeah snow makes everything slow
you know we had the altitude we didn't
have you know like warm food they didn't
have food at all we had some uh and um
but the thing is like it's technically
it was really complex this movie so it
has a lot of techniques mixed together
because we have we had a stage we had
led screens but also we had most of the
mov shot in an real exterior in the snow
and also we we had all the back all the
backgrounds you see are real footage
from the real and these mountains where
they were they they they were amazed
that the looks you see when you get into
um on the scenes on the where where
where you when you are in uh around the
plane it's exactly what they saw and I
think the
the the technical complexity it was
something that uh
we dealt with it day by day and then we
had to deal with the other difficulties
of like you know like being in the snow
being in the altitude you were asking me
like uh how did I smoke up there uh and
I quit uh but uh but uh but but it was
it was it was a big ass yeah well I the
my my memory of my whopping two days was
that uh the lenses kept getting foggy
and freezing over the equ was that was
my biggest issue I don't see how you
manag this for 100 how many day 100,000
day what how many
100,000 uh 140 we lost count after
143 right so some people say 150 some
people say
147 how because we actually we actually
went through the to the same place where
the plane crash and we shot there for 20
days yeah and we don't we don't count
count those days because basically were
backgrounds yeah um um I mean basically
technically we had to turn on the
cameras inside a place that has that
wasn't so freezing so the cameras will
turn on there and then take them out and
then the lenses will have to be cold
already so they were right kept cold the
thing with the lenses you we couldn't
like bring cold lenses to a warm place
because they would like fog and freeze
and it was a mess but in the
Avalanche like that was stage but it was
real snow and it was cold because we had
air conditioning in our stage that was
at top of the mountain and uh and the
the the the camera operators will have
you know like napkins in their in their
pockets and they would like be cleaning
and clean that thing and then they were
cleaning and taking their hand out and
they were like crawling in the snow yeah
and then bags you know bags so the snow
doesn't get inside the camera but I I
have to ask this a bit of a nerd
question forgive me guys but uh the it
I couldn't it's not usually I can tell I
couldn't tell whether it was digital or
film looked kind of like film but I was
not I couldn't figure out what you did
yeah it's again it's a mixture of
techniques right but uh it it's
basically digital it was kind of under
underexposed a little bit and uh and
then it was after we finished the whole
movie after we had the VFX after we had
color we printed the movie on film and
then gave us that gave gave us you know
not only the grain but also a better
blending of the VFX you know a different
like texture to everything and a little
bit of a shift of colors and some help
with the highlights and that that we
scanned it back so yeah it's a mixture
of a lot of techniques yeah hence my
befuddlement
um I wanted this is not a question but
you can respond and I hope you do you're
a very arod dite man
so I watched the film and it has the
single most hopeless moment I've ever
seen in a movie which is when they look
out and it looks
endless you know the moment of course
you made the picture why am I telling
you he was there and he was there it is
it is one of the most hopeless moments
in a movie about hope that I've I I
cannot it it was I remember I watched it
and my reaction was like it was it's
devastating
and yet here it is it's not a question
all you just talk about it because
you're such a smart guy thank you you're
welcome uh come I I want also Roberto to
talk about it because I I interviewed
the survivors for many many many hours
to try to understand them and try to get
the details to I was obsessed with
detail and and small gestures because
being a film that has a story that has
been shot T ice already before this one
I was trying to get uh through the
scenes from different from different
from a different angle to make them look
different and had a different also
meaning and I remember that to me that
moment was the realization that the plan
was wrong that they were wrong so
basically they they they they spend the
whole film talking about what should we
do and suddenly when they decide to do
this idea of going to uh to the east
they were wrong and and I envisioned
that moment like a moment of calm like
being very calm because at that moment
they they know they're dead so if you
have lost any hope if you have that as
you said that hopeless moment suddenly
you don't
fight you don't need to fight it's okay
we're dead and and then they have a
beautiful conversation they talk about
the
view uh they talk about he's he's the
one saying such a shame that we we are
already dead right how how do how do you
see because it was not like that right
that the
moment
um there are moments in your life in
which your brain must be stronger than
your
feelings it's a a brain problem I KN we
knew that to the West Was Chile
someplace by the map couldn't be more
than 70 kilometers so if we could walk
in in that direction someplace we will
get out of the mountain so there was a
conviction when we saw the mountains we
realized that ER it going was going to
be harder than what he thought and then
and Nando is shortsighted but I could
see two roads on the Argentinian side
and I told him Nando we are going the
wrong way we should go the other
way and then ER I don't see any road
and we knew by the map that the on the
Argentinian side was more desertic and
maybe we we could find ourselves lost in
a desert so we had to counterbalance
many of these aspects in that decision
making on the other hand Nando wouldn't
go he wouldn't go back he the my only
the only chance was to go to to the West
so and uh and he's Russian and I am
Italian so I said tomorrow I will give
you an answer because you shouldn't take
the decisions on the evening because
you're tired you must wait for the next
day and on the next day was spectacular
day the mountain the it had snowed and
you could see the the the powder snow
that would be like the hair of a of a
woman that was moving around those days
that you would swallow the world and we
and then say we had enough we should go
on and we begin sliding on the other
side for 200 or 300 MERS and then the
this the The Avalanches would be around
and they said this is dienal I want to
go home but my home was in that
direction but but also to me I I I to me
it's like your your first instinct when
you when you play a moment like that is
that they will start to argue and to me
it was a moment of agreement because
this to me Roberto andando they they are
a very cinematic couple you know I I
remember I was telling the actors Matias
and and Austine the example you remember
I don't know the name in English but we
had these Hannah Barbara cartoons
Roberto it was they call lagarto juano
and Leon Triston I don't know it was a
lizard and a lion all the time are like
running in the cartoons and are all the
time are are yeah exactly and all the
time are are are arguing each other it's
like donkey hot and Sancho pan is like
Captain KK and Dr and spoke they they
are all the time arguing but they don't
they don't realize but they are the same
person they are they are two two halves
of the first of the same person so to me
that was the moment that they are one at
the top of that mountain so they don't
need to argue they know they're dead
there's nothing else to argue they just
need to sit down and enjoy the view and
actually they they they they spent a
long time there I did these three
dissolved things that I copy from
another film I'm not going
to I'm not going to tell you what film
was up but
I ah it's you will never guess
it uh and it's a moment of it's a
peaceful moment it's we're dead okay and
and suddenly they are one they they stop
arguing for the first time in the film
they stop
arguing I want to know your relationship
with your actors and how he talks to you
and you talk to him I could this is a
very it's again a unique
circumstance right you don't work on
blocking very
much okay in this scene you're sitting I
mean you know what I'm saying so what
are you guys talking about or are are
you do do you guys do you leave your
actors alone what's the relationship
like with with
Enzo I prefer him to answer
first so it will be like a test like
like that's
fine
[Music]
for
op
[Music]
uh incredible uh in uh in Truth uh H is
a person that prepares a lot that
rehearses a lot but then there is a lot
of freedom uh on the set
so we improvised a lot and so what would
happen I would prepare a scene a lot the
night before prepare and prepare and
then next day come ready to film and
then we got handed new papers for the
scene that hot just wrote the night
before and we would talk for five
minutes get uh
directions and ask any questions and
then we would begin filming and doing
this scene after scene we discovered New
Perspectives and new nuances uh in the
work that we were doing and um this is
the type of work that leaves you on your
toes expecting awake and um the
direction that we got was incredible and
we also had coaches that were amazing
and they acted as a bridge between H and
us and they helped us understand what
was intended they showed us the path and
what was the vision uh behind it and
this was this work was a constant and it
was it's the type of work where you
don't feel alone and it was a wonderful
way to
work I'm going to I'm going to feel now
very very intellectual and arrogant I'm
gonna I'm going to quote Jan Jan lart he
has this famous line he says the the
shoot Destro the
script the editorial destroys the shoot
you know which B basically it's a
thought on that it's a constant search
and it's a constant process so when I
change an idea on the day we are
shooting if I change an idea is not
because I thought about it in that
moment is the result of all the homework
I've done until that moment so you keep
changing all thinking all the time all
the time and then when when you see the
actor you have the chance to react for
the first time to what's what's
happening you can see it and in that
moment you can you can you can you can
take a a different decision that is it
will be not that different it would be
like One Step Beyond what was planned uh
so and and what I I I I love to work
with actors I really love to work with
actors I gave them all the information I
we we we
did like seven weeks of rehearsals we
went through all the film then I put
them in contact with the the survivors
in your case with the family of Numa and
they were they they they established a
relation you you were talking to the
family of Numa during all the shoot and
and then I I like to provide him the the
context so so we we were shooting in the
snow they were able to feel the the cold
they were going through a street diet so
they were experiencing also and you try
to suggest um and create emotions
similar to the ones you're watching on
the screen of course we we'll never be
the same but for example uh one of to me
one of the most beautiful memories is
when we shot uh the day that Numa dies
because he was the the protagonist he
was the lead actor and because we were
shooting chronologically after so many
days uh he was leaving the set so all
the actors knew that that was his last
day and you can tell by their faces that
they were suffering for that they were
suffering because they will never see
and so anymore they they they they were
going to be keep shooting the film
without him respectfully I have to
interrupt you and because I don't know
I'm sure this is a room full of
filmmakers but if whoever isn't that is
unbelievable what he just said shooting
a movie in sequence is extremely rare
particularly a movie like this it's
beyond rare that blows me away you shot
it in sequence you have to lose weight
so we have to do it like that God
that is ABS that's
astonishing it made it a lot harder
because
uh you can improvise but not that much
and and when you shoot in the snow it's
always the montine who's ruling the
situation we we had three planes
remember and we had to check the weather
forecast every day and decide what to
shoot the day after because we were
depending on the weather and we were
able to uh adapt but not that much
because we were shooting
chronologically God Almighty well my
question you then would be if you you're
shooting
chronologically 140 days of this thing
shooting Chron don't you lose your way
at some point it sort of becomes like a
kind of Madness I I
yeah yes but you have time to go right
you know yeah no I understand that are
you editing as you're going or you one
of those people that just you are so
then when you're giving him notes it's
on stuff you've on the movie that you've
assembled yeah and since you're going
would you show would you see this stuff
some of the stuff I would see uh but I
mean it's it's it had the advantage that
we can change a little bit some stuff
because we were going forward we didn't
have to redo stuff right I mean we we
are redoing some stuff that H Us Saw oh
yeah we did that scene and then then we
need you know second unit to
like clean up this scene a little bit
but we
could create it as we went because we
were going
chronologically we didn't shoot the
ending and then we had to come back so
you're you're basically you went twice
to the sort of civilized world so to
speak right for the beginning and the
end that and in between you did that
whole thing it wasn't basically we no we
we started a sh uh after the crash right
and then we shot all the whole thing and
then we went to U and shot the ending
right the hospital and stuff then we
waited uh and and they gained wait again
right we waited like a month and a half
and they ate a lot and they became rag
beers and then we shot the beginning I
see and then we shot the whole beginning
and then we had to build the whole crash
uh the plane crash uh and then we went
to Madrid and we shot that thing so
you're shooting the big beginning
essentially after everything but that
was actually very good because after so
much time together yeah were you you can
tell the chemistry the warmth you know
but don't you have the undertoe of a
Melancholy that you don't want because
there it's something that's already
happened that shouldn't have if that
makes sense you didn't feel that at all
your your is pretty melancholic already
so I think
yeah it's prettyy dark huh especially in
the winter yeah in yeah it's a very no
it was a very hard shoot you know the
the most difficult to me the most
difficult part of the shoot every day
was to step out of my bed because I
knew that I had so much every day and we
we were depending on the weather so so
you could shoot a a a simple scene but
then you will wake up and there was this
day that we woke up and the whole
Mountain was orange because we had this
wind from from the from the desert from
the Sahara dragging the Sun and suddenly
the mountain looked like orange yeah it
was literally like Dunes suddenly I mean
there's this wind that comes from the
Sahara Desert that brings dust and it's
no dust in the
mountains we woke up one
day it's the first time in 20 years that
yeah yeah okay I know that story is the
first time in 20 years yes so yeah and
that happens and then you know we had to
adapt luckily that I mean it lasted a
little bit we went to shoot interiors
and we shot as much as we could and at
one point there was a big storm and
everything went white again and uh but
it was a little bit tricky because if if
you stepped in the snow you know there
was a little layer of like chocolate in
the middle it was like an inverted
Oreo well um unfortunately I'm getting
the you know the the the sign but I want
to ask one quick question one quick
question because do two quick questions
inste of one you got to run you got to
go and R the screening after this buddy
I don't want to I got nothing to do with
that I got nothing to do with that um
jakino is not here we love Michael
jakino he's great man yeah legendary
composer already he loves you too he
told me yesterday right well I already
liked him
uh when you have music and when you
don't talk me through that decision
process with him that was very
interesting because it was such an
emotional Journey like like every every
scene was so emotional that he came with
uh with a lot of constraint like like
using silence and and basically
like it was the same thing with the
sound with the sound design uh in it was
like those painters that that work from
a black canvas not not the light you
know so so and the moment you add a a a
single white dot is so meaningful and
the music is the same uh actually I I I
likeed so much his approach that I I I
took a lot of his music once in the
Final Mix because it it worked really
well and and he loved that he was always
like supporting my my
ideas
um he he he he was very good in that
like like the good thing about Michael
is is he's a a great musician but he's
an even a better Storyteller yes I know
Michael since like 15 years ago we he
came to a film music festival in Spain I
was very young at that time uh we we
immediately we became friends and every
time I've done a
film before uh locking the cat I I come
to LA and show him the film and and and
it was a big coincidence that they
offered me to do the sequel for Jurassic
W and he was the composer of the first
Jurassic world so I called him and I say
okay I guess we're going to work
together for the after so many years
being friends
and and I showed him this film and
immediately he wanted to do it he said I
I I want I want to I want to be part of
this journey with
you well it's a marvelous picture and I
I can't thank you enough for all coming
thank you so
much and thank you
[Music]
James